walk in to this video playing
international mass let's eat dark out 26
Gabrielle but tell jeannie ok let's see
maybe we get a modern defense or
transposition to the Kings in India it
is a king's indian transposition trying
the fianchetto variation again let's see
what he is going for his the big parting
of the ways 97 c 5 yes all kinds of
lines ok so we go to him to a
symmetrical variation of the English
opening haha very early Queen system ok
they are normally the the queen is just
misplaced on c7 in this line quite
clearly misplaced let's let's see the
reason is that very often night is
coming to d5 with with pretty pretty
good effect so let's see so he's trying
to correct this in a way yeah I can I
can play it in two different ways i can
i can allow the exchange em and this is
what i'm going to do or play play a
rupee one and Bishop h1 but i don't mind
to get this maroc see by instructure
it's just the typical slide space
advantage that that white has may have
played this this opening quite quite
often so let's see um 9325 is probably
what i want to do yeah 94 94 it's not
playable i can just take that
connects the packages oh man great
people want to sell something at the
door great idea okay so he can go here
and what what I was thinking here and
have lost some time I mean 94 is nothing
that that scares me much but still I
hadn't taken that into account I maybe
95 Noah I can I can take the knight on
d4 is not not supported in any way so i
can go 95 form
night ed five or nine cd5 I like this
maybe I can maybe I can play a Nigeria
after the the traitor
okay so this is this is nice here I'm
going to take come on keep it keep it
simple then the check check and now I
have 94 I'm not sure how how when
problematic it is I can also try drive
for no energy form or is this not really
a threat probably isn't really a threat
nope okay I can play at the Messiah h4
h5 for example it's just done nice for
me anyway okay cannot he cannot play a
sacrifice and 93 is just not leading to
anything
now the problem is i have this knight on
d5 and with the Queen only six he can
never get it or drive it away with these
six looks very nice for wine this 93
moves I'll just play Queen deform and
it's a retreat time again for the night
ok so the edge file is where my book
belongs headsets clear
yeah f4 get so gets interesting very
much in very interesting pushing the
night away here from be five and then
maybe yeah okay but 96 nite nite g4s is
basically winning it or not I think here
and and resins on does he have a move
night x f4 maybe
hmm it's very nice and in any case but
let's uh let's see Knight g4 night f4
check i can again maybe it just king of
three it's night h6 checkmate that's
it's very serious and Knight f6 winning
the Queen it's really a quite something
yeah I don't I don't see I don't see a
reply one minute to let the only problem
f6 maybe it looks terrible but maybe
have six
maybe I should have taken refers on g6
and then night you for this was maybe
better what okay maybe we'll see
check 9h six mate and Knight f6 winning
the queen with a series of checks so
what exactly is you move now I thought
f6 was the only plan will move and take
him time morning still by the Queen yeah
take care he has 95 chicken
check
checkmate yeah this was a very bad
position out of the opening really bad I
think that around here why this is
slightly better only but his very weird
setup here with 94 and so this is just
just miss placing pieces I here before
would already win the game okay I didn't
see that this was around the time when
it doorbell rang before why is this
winning hmm and goes back at cv5 I this
consisted this straps the Queen yeah the
Queen only six this is just just better
bet in any way but ok the way we'd way I
played is it's not bad it's not winning
but Jack it's not bad Jim compounds to
play before here with a big edge okay
yeah age five yeah there are many
improvements here actually this isn't
this is even better Janice wins material
yeah I played I played it by far not in
the best way but the blackest is so so
bad in his position oh and interesting
okay well this wins but this is this is
not even even stronger very nice first
sacrificing and then setting up this
Knight takes f6 this is deadly here very
nice look at this line under and it's
it's over Queen takes charge six check
great ok but ok this is winning as well
check check yeah and he could have
spared himself the
yeah it's a bit bit weird because this
is already a bit strange and the
position is it's still okay here but it
starts with this move why why why put
the Queen on this bed square on e6 just
bet square you want to have maybe at
some point e 6 to get rid of the D 59
and here you always will get the
situation where night will come to d5
and you are not going to be able to
expel it so I'm like is in trouble and
that didn't even use it properly okay
thanks for watching